for me the unique thing when I look at
it even now is when I watch a film like
lady in the [ __ ] it's not a film about
dogs it's a film told from the dogs
point of view and like what John was
just saying everything we figured out in
terms of design and even a lot of
character certainly a lot of gags came
from the fact that they were real toys
and they treated each other like real
toys they were adult toys as well like
John was saying earlier but everything
about the film from the lighting and
cinematography that a design and how
they saw the world the scale of things
was from a toys point of view it's taken
for granted now but if you watch the
film with that in your head it's
remarkable
you know I still am kind of floored by
that it's actually an easy thing to do
and an incredibly hard thing to do
you're also creating a new cinematic
language and I know you were doing
lighting Galen
but camera sort of ties into lighting
and and there were decisions made about
what the camera platform would be and I
noticed that we take it for granted now
but but the camera you can do anything
with a camera but you chose to ground
the camerawork and the lighting as
though it were alive a live-action
feature can you speak to that a little
bit absolutely that was one of the first
things that you had said was we are not
doing flying logos we're making a movie
which for for those of us
you have to realize back then the the
people who are doing dealing with the
technology were technologists we were
not filmmakers at the time we didn't
understand film language we were simply
you know doing whatever we were told in
terms of trying to just get graphic
images on the screen by programming as
quickly as we could to get the pictures
made and so it's like we're not doing
flying logos we're doing a real camera
what does what does that mean
we had no clue what that meant and so
going into you know the study of lenses
in the study of cameras and and how how
do cameras work and it was it was all
just really a big mystery and we were
learning along the way and and it was
really just John keeps saying it's not
flying logos it's a film and a film a
shot from a camera of the camera being
on a tripod for there are a lot of shots
in Toy Story where the the where the
tripod is attached to the camera is
actually just behind the lens and you
know we've kind of moved it back up and
and then little things like that they
make a huge difference it's also
hand-drawn animation it's
two-dimensional and I are emitters are
projected in two dimensions so you want
that clarity but the thing that the
lighting and the textures brought to it
was this it's not live-action and it's
not hand-drawn animation it's somewhere
in the middle it's almost like a amalgam
of all of those things and theater you
know because everything's kind of
presented in a theatrical way we said
you know we would always talk about that
that what we're creating is some are
bending hand-drawn animation in
live-action but it's not in one place
for every aspect of the film we would
always say that the design of what we're
doing is a little closer to hand-drawn
animation in it's a caricatured world we
never ever ever wanted the audience to
look up on the screen and think we were
trying to reproduce reality we had a
saying back in the days because
everybody was in it was trying to create
computer animation tools to to do
something that looked absolutely real
and we always said that reality is just
a convenient measure of complexity
meaning that you use that as a tool to
create something that's absolutely real
great I have that tool now I'm gonna
step back from reality produce something
through the audience from every single
frame knows this doesn't exist and then
make it look as real as possible and
that's where the design of the world was
always very cartoony but as John was
saying the the camerawork the
understanding of of the lighting of the
camera we really wanted to and we've
studied deeply the limitate what were
used to watching a motion picture film
up on the screen is based what feels
right is based upon the limitations of
the filmmakers have had for for decades
and decades and decades of these large
cameras on dollies on cranes on things
like they couldn't move that camera
around it wasn't till the Steadicam came
along today the filmmakers could
actually move the camera in unique in
different ways and so so we
were always striving to kind of
understand the film grammar that was
used based upon the limitations of the
camera and and so that's what we govern
to all of our camera moves the other
thing is it's that one of the inventions
that Pixar did was based upon the need
for motion blur right motion blur you
know in a motion picture camera it's got
the the shutter unlike your your your
SLR or something like that that kind of
goes the the motion that the camera has
basically a spinning wheel inside a
35-millimeter camera and if they call it
a 180 degree shutter half of that wheel
is open half of its closed as its
spinning it goes to you know twenty
basically the equivalent of 24 frames a
second and while while the the the part
of the wheel that solid is over the film
plane that's when it's advanced and the
film stops and it goes around and it's
the open part of the wheel it's turning
exposes the film and so the shutter
speed of 35 millimeter is always exactly
the same it's not like your your camera
at home that you can change it it's
always exactly the same
therefore when you're watching a movie
there's a certain amount of motion blur
that is always consistent and without it
it doesn't look convincing it doesn't
feel like a film an early computer
animation it was all crystal clear no
matter how fast something was moving it
was all crystal clear and it never felt
like a movie it never felt like a movie
and and one of the things that Edie Edie
and his team developed was was the
ability to do motion blur which actually
the same technology led to depth of
field yeah the the there's a
physiological reason why there's a
problem well you need the motion blur it
was in fact the use of motion blur with
optics that were ILM was capturing the
motion blur of real spaceships against
and then having this great science
behind maintaining that motion blur all
the way through the optical matting but
it's very difficult and we knew that in
order have SMA like Star Wars
so unique in what was done because it
was
all the spaceships are flying around and
had true motion blur and it looks other
than that it would have you have seen
this sort of doubling up at the edge
even though you wouldn't notice it
consciously but I subconsciously you
know something's wrong we had to solve
the problem to make it so that computer
graphics could be used in filmmaking but
in doing so we also enabled the
special-effects revolution and it was
that motion blur that was the difference
and when you and when you do the
opposite which is using like a 90 degree
shutter or a skinny shutter that's the
opening of Saving Private Ryan where it
all feels very dreamlike and chattery so
what they're trying to do is is make it
feel as organic as possible but it also
using squash and stretch also which is
another thing that you well that's where
in the animation and the timing and
everything like that again we're on the
spectrum between hand-drawn animation
and in live-action are we well in the
animation it's all directly you know
using all the principles of animation
that Walt Disney in the nine old men and
all the great animators at Disney you
know kind of invented we also studying
Chuck Jones was a mentor of mine and
setting the great animation of Ken
Harris and all of the Warner Brothers
cartoons in and we wanted to achieve
that in in what we were doing so that's
where that's where this uniqueness of
what Toy Story was in this computer
animation it was a movie it was lit it
was dimensional we had cameras moving
around through things we had Steadicam
kind of shots all that stuff and it felt
like a movie yet they were cartoony and
they were moving like cartoons and yet I
could touch them they were plastic you
know and it was all that that kind of
uniqueness because again understanding
the limitations of what the medium was
at that time and creating you know the
characters and the storytelling and
everything because you know frankly
everything looked like plastic so we
made the main characters made of plastic
Buzz Lightyear you know organic
especially ground planes was impossible
to do at that time so luckily toys are
found in kids rooms which are all flat
floors so it lent itself it's our
knowledge of the limitations of the
medium lent itself to the
subject matter but everything else was
like we had to invent you know and and
and it was it was incredible we would
kind of you know something in the story
we would look at each other and how are
we gonna do that now everything was done
programming wise initially I mean we we
placed lights by writing code there were
no interactive programs to place things
so you would you would write a line of
code that would place a light and try to
aim it and try to set its color and its
breath and then you'd hit a button and
you go get a cup of coffee and then you
come back and you would look at the
image and say wow that's not quite right
and then you go back and you open the
program and you'd change the line of
code and it was just it's hard for
people to imagine I remember when we got
our first interactive modeling program
and the first thing I got to model was
the Pizza Planet truck and it was the
notion that you could take a mouse and
click a point and then the point would
show up on the screen but mind-blowing